rénovation renforcement de la chaussée
ou encore aménagement des routes
les travaux des dés sont lancés dans les
yvelines sur les 1600 km de routes pas
moins de 70 chantiers sont prévus dans
68 communes
l'objectif pour le département assurer
le bon état des routes et prévenir les
risques d'accidents dans ses travaux
d'été on trouve différents types de
travaux donc des travaux d'aménagement
de circulations douces comme ce qu'on
voit ici sur la piste cyclable bucs tous
eu des travaux d'aménagement de sécurité
routière donc ça peut être des travaux
d'aménagement de carrefour rectification
de carrefour création d'un giratoire
voit la reprise de virages
enfin tout ce qui est lié à la sécurité
routière aux déplacements des usagers
chaque année l'entretien des voiries et
travaux coûtent 10 millions d'euros et
le département n'a pas choisi la période
estivale par hasard - de circulation des
températures idéales mais surtout moins
de gêne pour les usagers
certaines routes seront fermées ou en
circulation alternée
la sécurité routière c'est fondamental
quand il y à des zones dites
accidentogène on essaye de les résorber
on ne le fait pas seul on le fait en
partenariat bien évidemment avec les
communes parce que vous imaginez bien
que si vous intervenez dans un axe au
coeur d'une ville il faut quand même
qu'on le prépare ensemble et le
financement est partagé avec la région
parce qu'il y à des programmes justement
de sécurité
des travaux d'été qui ne devrait durer
que quelques semaines mais parmi les
grands chantiers celui de la rd30 qui
entre dans sa dernière phase et devrait
se terminer prochainement